yes my question to you is if an  individual is living in the United  States of America without documents and  that is his only offense should that  person be deported depending if they  committed a major crime they should be  deported and the president was left in  as President Obama I think did a heck of  a job to compare him to what what this  guy is doing is absolutely I find close  to immoral but the fact is that look we  should not be locking people up we  should be making sure we change the  circumstance as we did why they would  leave in the first place and those who  come seeking asylum we should  immediately have the capacity to absorb  them keep them safe until they can be  heard a 15 second if you could if you  wish the answer should someone who is  here without documents and that is his  only offense should that person be  deported that person should not be the  focus of deportation we should  fundamentally change the way we deal  with